ich weiß nicht ob ich in meiner lieben
freunde und herzlich willkommen zurück
bei der epischen spring karte zusammen
mit komme hna.de auch auch ab
der perfekte start das war vorhin
teleportiert euch am besten schnell ok
mache ich mich ja sollte ihr müsst
wissen ich bin mittlerweile auch schon
gestorben
durch kontrast natürlich und ich habe
dabei meine gastrede alle beide punkte
verloren
dann waren wir an der stelle hier
kontrakt david brennan an der trümmer
wie ein wasserbecken konkreter wollte er
ein rennen in der letzten sekunde
millisekunde war danach sichtlich
geschafft alle da lagen an die punkte
von ihm hatten zwei punkte
ich sammle die auf war dann hier bei dem
sprung was macht er schubst mich einfach
runter das war schon sehr sehr ethnisch
dass das war wie kino schon ein
tipps
nein nein nicht nicht schlagen
kontrastreiches lage nicht mehr ich bin
jetzt friedlich doch so unglaublich
risiko ich habe geschafft
ich habe geschafft ich auch ich habe
geschafft haben sind wir wieder bei null
das heißt der jetzt die nächste krieg
das wird jetzt der wird dann wird dann
wieder für stoppschilder ich will die
kiste nein das nix drin aber das sind
alles mögliche von apple und schuhe so
ok wo müssen wir lange nein nein ich bin
da recht auf den weg ich gehe hier lange
fertig ist links sonst wird das hier
nicht so ausgeschildert nein die weg ich
will ich weiß schon was kommt ja weg da
die profis am werk
nein das war meine wirklichkeit fakt
becker ja okay ich nehm langer weg
dass sein keller bis zum 6 ich werde
hier schön mit dem punkten geld abholen
nein nein nein nie wie hast du dich da
dennoch bekommen du mit einer fünf meter
handel gegen den blauen ob ist doch dass
ich mal richtig zeit ja ja ich hab da
kommt am ende wieder nur ein apfel
ortsschild julia traunstein bereich vom
liedern guckt mich nicht alt ich kann
ihn nicht ins gesicht kommt mir bei
minecraft immer deine nase nein eine
chance nein nein weil ich möchte die
punkte wie vielleicht manche nicht
mitbekommen haben wir machen ja mit den
punkten klar wie berichtet auch wenn
sein konto auf der tour ist nicht neu
ja habe ich auch gerade geguckt kann man
da nicht werden hoch erscheint nicht
unerheblich weil geschafft hättest du
mich da mal eben gerade nicht
weggeschlagen
aber meine nein
was soll das konto
nein nein nicht nicht ich schlag dich
nicht weil du dann eher schneller wir
fordern wir dass
nein dort
gleichauf dietrich hoppe was klicken ja
ich guck mich nach oben
und er steht da versteht da natürlich
der grand cru auf da war doch klar warum
stehst du da auch aber der controller
man kann mit dir einfach keine karten
spielen nur weil du machen ich habe
schon shift gedrückt weil ich dachte du
schlägst du ich wir werden nicht beide
paranoid hinter den decks wieder da ich
habe das gefühl er findet keine punkte
das wäre als engel mit alex bin nein vom
blauen wisst ich hatte richtig viel
vorsprung
ich hab noch unter es reicht halt stopp
so geht das nicht
so geht das ja echt nicht meins natur
nicht so nur mit einem apfel du schaffst
das e
nein ach komm dass wir sechs minuten
hier um dich jetzt in anderen weg so du
kannst du von mir aus lange gehalten das
sagst du nur stellte hier kriege ich die
dienst und das bei dir noch packe drin
er sage ich ja werden
und du bist wirklich mal oben lagen
hätte ich gar nicht erwartet von mir
es wird aber auch echt langweilig hier
langsam dann alltag ohne man kann er
doch eigentlich durch sprinten wenn man
das richtig macht war alter lassen
wollte nur mal die hand geben
okay das war beide ohne dass ich hab das
ist und nicht mal ich hab ich schaff ich
hab's geschafft bunte ich hab einen
punkt an schall da wollten wir ganz
wichtiger ist es einfach nur geld
schreib mal in die kommentare
hd ist hof ich musste gerade ganz kurz
die man vom mikrofon weg und die tür
schließen
ok ich arbeite wer führt na sag es
ausspricht aus wer führt wir wissen kann
sich das alles noch ändern ich weiß wie
ich hatte 12.10 dann hattest du wieder
mehr und dann gehe ich dann naja aber
einfach spielst
red in schalter wahrscheinlich musste
schalter
hätte gran torino ein glück meine sachen
linie sogar wir sind werden wir sollen
da gar nicht hoch doch anscheinend schon
weil man könnte doch eigentlich auch
hier weiter laufen
da probiere mal hat er steht da kommt
nach hinten erst wenn wir die anderen
lernen teil hier der karte geschafft
haben stand aufgestellt können dann
machen wir es hier schon richtig jetzt
erstmals einen kuchen hin
ok vielen dank ich hoffe er ist auch von
der geballten dank für den puren
schokokuchen vielen dank dass ein
checkpoint euch komm ran
wirklich achtung checkpoint com
hey ärmlich es war gebe ich dir da die
punkte geschenkt überhaupt nicht
schenken
so
nein nur das wäre es hier noch schwierig
und ja dass du den jackpot nimmst muss
man in irland ja hier weiter nach oben
noch weiter
nein ich habe es gleich ich bin gleich
oben ich bin wirklich gleich oben und
schon wären check point oberst gold
double check point all dem was herr
huber ich glück dass ich in hand halte
unter die haut gelegt
ich hab dachte ich hab den punkt
eingesammelt schneller langsamer richtig
blöde salvadori wird immer nach oben
bitte stopp stopp stopp
nein hab ich mal stirbt doch intense ich
habe alle meine alten sachen wieder
ja aber wir kommen voran auf jeden fall
mal wieder hier ein bisschen her finde
ich ja gut ich war richtig weiter
bestimmt du weißt doch hat es darum dass
das nochmal
da liegen die punkte und ich bin extra
so runter was ich hab die punkte
den punkt den werde ich behalten das ist
meiner
so kommen wir bis jetzt bisschen
vorankommen hier
wir kommen doch an in der folge hier es
regnet gerade wenn ich sage wir wollen
vorankommen
ich schwimme hier gerade evo merklich
deswegen ja gar nicht es ist kurz
schwimmen draußen wenn es regnet ja
stimmen warte ich mal regen aus kita du
hast den ring ausgestellt helm muss ich
nach berlin und ich hab's geschafft am
schalter hilfe ja moment ich bin auch
gleich da ich muss mich nur mal einen
moment ja ich glaube zu bauen nicht
unter weil ich gerade direkt bevorsteht
sie können uns währenddessen ich kann
magda reinpacken
und ich will man ihm ein schalter lebt
noch und hier liegt um einen punkt das
schalter okay ich hab den schalter einen
punkt und ich habe es geschafft er gar
nicht
gehen wir einen schritt nach hinten
bitte bis bei mir unsichtbar bitte ein
schritt nach vorne an die wand
ich habe es geschafft eigenartig jetzt
macht er links daraufhin mit nein
man geht
haben jetzt schon geschafft was man da
war noch was soll das einfach nur sneak
peek von version 1.2 aber da können wir
noch hin
ja da können wir hier aber 1.2 habe ich
schon gespielt
ach kommt noch ein komplett neuer teil
hatte
ja also das ist halt so aufgebaut dass
es so nacheinander ab 1 ok und hier kann
man scheint weiter machen oder wie ja so
dass es dann auf jeden fall erstmal die
letzte folge aber hier das polster
angucken wie das so weitergehen
oh ja total schön hier also richtig hat
das nie dosen richtig geilen ein blick
auf jeden fall ein wald und ein wilder
contra das ist der einblick in die
zukunft ich hab gewonnen hätten hätten
wir unentschieden
aber ich habe hier dann in der karte wir
wollen von den punkten her
naja ab kleine abmachung
die mit dem punkte was für punkte die
gas drehen was wir was für das training
natürlich habe jetzt eine gute idee was
ich mache ich hier holz ab und dann darf
ich ihnen schwer
und dann sie wichtig und dann tot
und dann meine punkte bekommt es nicht
doch doch nein ganz bestimmt nicht nein
du hast schon schwer hier kommen
darunter hier
nein stellt nach oben schnell nach oben
ja ich habe die sachen ich hab die du
bist viel muss ich was ist das denn
was hast du bist ein sichtbar wo bist du
das ist das ist schicken
du bist bei mir unsichtbar ja immer noch
ja wo bist du weiter ich gebe meinem
creative mode hier rum
scheiße hallo noch da
elcon crafter ja meine punkte bekommen
zunächst war er ist er kann noch ein wo
tnt im hintergrund hochgegangen nein das
war nicht eingesetzt habe na gut meine
lieben freunde das war es dann erstmal
mit ich hab die punkte außerdem
versteckt wie hast du die karte ich fand
es eigentlich ganz gut hier zu gast oben
kommt er denn hin
ich würde eher möglich
zehn von zehn diamanten geben ich weiß
nicht warum aber ich finde auf jeden
fall
ich finde gerade die sprünge die sind
bald wieder in ordnung die sind manchmal
schwer manchmal einfach und ich finde
man hat hier nicht immer das gefühl
nicht durchgehen so ein gefühl von euch
gibt auch keinen bock mehr hat er
wirklich wir gefühl man möchte hier
weiter machen dann richtig die neuen
abschnitte der karte noch erkunden und
auch die gestaltung der karte die finde
ich wirklich gut und auch das etwas das
er noch etwas training mit dabei war
fand ich auch richtig geil und ich kann
dir nur recht geben zehn von zehn
diamanten für die karte ii auf jeden
fall dass es unsere bewertung wie man
wenn es euch gefallen hat dürft ihr eine
positive bewertung lassen wenn es euch
gefallen hat wenn ich dann halt archiv
wenn ich dann halt nicht und schreib
doch mal passieren damit bisher am
geilsten fahne beziehen was ihr an uns
beiden zu entfernen
wenn jetzt einfach alles teilen aber ja
weil mir meine momente immer nur so ein
paar momente neben sind so ein prozent
des videos keil bei mir so 90